كما تشاهدون تستمر عمليه تشييع الجثامين
تباعا ومواوراتهم الثرى الى مثواهم الاخير
في مقبره بيت لاهيا شمال القطاع غزه اااا
ال- الاجواء هنا يعني
تعجز الكلمات عن وصفها كما تشاهدون هناك
حاله تدافع كبيره الالاف شاركت في عمليه
التشييع تشيع جثامين ضحايا هذا الحادث
المفجع بالنسبه لقطاع غزه بشكل كامل ولكن
السؤال الكبير رغم حاله الحزن والصدمه
والوجوم هو كيف لي نيران ان تلتهم في بيت
واحد كل هذه الاعداد الكبيره ولذلك فتحت
التحقيقات من الجهاد المختصه للوقوف على
السبب الدقيق والمباشر لهذه الفاجعه التي
المت بعائله ريا وسبائهم وهمم لاعلانها
على الراي يا عم تفاديا لتكرار مثل هذه
الحوادث التي عاده ما تذكر بواقع قطاع غزه
ال- ال- الذي يرزح تحت حصار مشدد منذ نحو
16 عاما من قبل اسرائيل وائل الدحدوح
الجزيره شمال القطاع غزه